over the last few months we've been
talking about the trials and
tribulations for independent news and
politics on YouTube
and a viewer posted on our subreddit a
question that brings up a really
interesting point about all this which
is might left-wing YouTube channels like
the david pakman show and so many others
might we simply be collateral damage in
the serious fight against extremism on
youtube I want to take this seriously
but first let me sort of catch you up on
what's been going on if you haven't
heard youtube over the last year has
been deprioritized
our content we have had a reduction by
about two-thirds or more in terms of the
views that we get by YouTube's algorithm
saying oh you like this other news and
politics thing go and check out the
David Pakman show they have increasingly
been saying go and check out cnn's
youtube channel or fox news's or the
mega corporate late-night talk shows not
the david pakman show that costs us
views so it costs us money YouTube has
been limiting monetization on anything
considered even remotely controversial
or sensitive in nature when you cover
news and politics everything you talk
about is potentially sensitive or
controversial in nature so that's not
been good so then in comes subreddit
shrub subreddit user
nudie which the david pakman show
subreddit of course at david pakman.com
slash re d di t and nu t says I recently
became a new subscriber of the david
pakman show both because i want to
support the channel now that youtube is
d monetizing content and because I
prefer the ad free experience I have
experienced the same issues that have
been reported by David YouTube
suggestions inevitably lead me back to
American mainstream corporate media even
when I rarely follow up on those
suggestions super done with Rachel
Maddow for example but they keep pushing
her however and this is the key part
I don't consider the new YouTube
algorithm to be a bad thing like many
many others I have had an anti an angry
anti sjw phase that was largely pushed
by a YouTube algorithm that drove me
from Sam Harris debate debates
evangelicals videos to Sargon and beyond
Nikolai's ation on YouTube is a real
problem David
secular talk and a few other progressive
independent media shows might just be
collateral damage in a very necessary
move to stop people from being
radicalized by a recommendations
mechanism that drives them into a
far-right conspiratorial fake news swamp
I do hope David will address this
possible upside of the new algorithm at
some point in the show what if it helps
stop Trump being reelected in 2020 in a
sense this viewer is exactly right
YouTube didn't go out and say we hate
independent news let's figure out a way
to hurt independent news or even more so
let's figure out a way to hurt left-wing
news or right-wing news on YouTube we
are a collateral damage but not of
YouTube wanting to rid itself of
extremism because they think it's the
right thing the truth is YouTube as an
institution cares about what is
profitable extremism actually is very
profitable in a sense in terms of watch
time when people get stuck in these echo
chamber rabbit holes of extremist
content if the content is monetized it
is massively profitable for YouTube so
YouTube as an institution doesn't care
about extremism per se
we're collateral damage of YouTube
wanting to preserve its profit and make
as much money as possible I talked about
this on the Joe Rogan program back in
June the path is simple we want to make
money when advertisers get upset we
don't make money as YouTube to keep
advertisers happy we need to pull
monetization from extremists and racist
content and we need to make sure that
that content is less searchable and less
recommended so let's put in place an
algorithm that white lists legacy
corporate channels and then basically
just makes guesses about independent
content and yeah the David Pakman show
and secular talk and others get caught
in that collateral damage now there is a
solution here channels like ours could
be whitelisted the David Pakman show
covers things like white supremacy we
cover racism we cover breaking news
we do it in an FCC safe way and we are
not advocating for extremist and we are
fighting it a real person or people
could look at our Channel and say we are
going to whitelist the David Pakman show
so that we keep recommending his videos
to the algorithm within the algorithm so
that monetization continues at a higher
rate because we want him to be
collateral damage to everything that we
are doing and in the meantime over the
weekend lots of people I was surprised
to hear from some prominent people
actually got in touch with me and said
David you've been talking about this for
a month I am now seeing it as well how
can I help what can I do but in practice
the simplest thing everybody can do some
version of fun the shows you want to
support directly that's what it is and I
know people get mad and say David I
watched 20 shows I can't support all of
them directly you're asking me to spend
$200 a month just on internet shows well
then pick a couple if you can afford it
if you can't then don't but the whole
point is we have a system in place
membership patreon which allows people
to get around all of these issues and
just say I like what you're doing I'm
gonna support it directly you don't have
to worry about monetization or D
monetization it doesn't have to be my
show that really is the path forward a
lot of people have been saying it for a
long time and it's never been more clear
than it is now